What is that?
Hey DNews listeners, Trace here.
Are you listening on headphones?
Turn up the volume really loud… hear that?
that hissing noise?
Okay, turn the volume back down.
Sorry ASMR peeps.
Okay, that hissing sound might be annoying,
but it's always there in speakers, headphones,
and electronics in general, even in your computer
and wifi signals!
How it gets there is kind of mind-blowing…
First, etymology time, baby!
*Sigh,* DNewsPlus.
The suffix -ics is from Greek -ikos meaning
"pertaining to."
Or Latin -ic "dealing with" or "denoting."
It's usually used with a body of facts or
knowledge, like: Log-IC, AcoustICS, mus-IC,
even mag-IC!
Electron-ICS denotes ELECTRONS.
When engineers design computers or headphones
or whatever, they take electrons and move
them through a system of wires and switches
to accomplish a task.
Headphones are simply tiny speakers attached
to the end of wires, not unlike the speakers
in your home theater, computer, or even at
the movies.
The electrons vibrate little cones or drivers
to push air around and make music.
In engineering vernacular, the music, data
(or whatever you’re transmitting) is called
the "signal," and everything else is called
"noise."
When assessing a system, engineers use something
called the signal-to-noise ratio.
The goal of headphones is to hear music, right?
So if you had a signal-to-noise ratio of 3-to-1,
the music is waay louder than the noise.
That's good!
But, if it's 1-to-1, then no matter how loud
the music was, the noise would still be there.
Okay, so, back to headphone hiss.
When electrons leave the battery, the charge
hops from atom to atom of the copper wires
of your device.
Every hop introduces a little bit of chaos!
A little bit of noise.
Just like molecules in a hot gas, electrons
in the circuitry are constantly jiggling about
in a random fashion, and the atoms are vibrating
too!
Plus, the wires are bent here or there, and
the copper isn't perfectly uniform -- those
little changes cause more interference and
more noise!
On top of that, wires aren't one continuous
stream, there are connections, chips, plugs,
and solders, each made of different materials
which cause the electrons to stutter or bounce
chaotically.
When I'm not talking, and you're still hearing
a hiss, that's called the "noise floor" and
hopefully it's low.
Amplifiers, home theaters, radios, smartphones
-- they all have noise floors.
The noise floor is there no matter what, just
by the system being turned on, but it can
also be dependent on what you're listening
to!
For example, CDs have almost no noise floor
because they've been remastered digitally
to remove any noise frequencies!
Cassette tapes on the other hand, are analog,
so they have some noise floor because of that,
and some from the magnetic tape itself.
The pops and cracks you hear when listening
to vinyl also contribute to the noise floor
but, in that case, some people actually like
the aesthetic.
At the end of the day, we humans perceive
a noise floor in our digital devices as that
hiss in our headphones.
So, when you turn up the volume, you're pushing
more power through the wires, like adding
flow to a water faucet… more electrons in
the wires can mean more noise.
Really good headphones can often pick up noise
that cheap headphones simply can't… but
cheap cables or cheap components can exacerbate
the hiss.
This is why some professional cables and high
end electronics cost so much, they're designed
to reduce this noise floor… and usually
have a higher signal-to-noise ratio: the signal
is stronger and clearer.
Most of the time it's not a big deal, unless
you're an audiophile…
But, in the end, you can't 100 percent escape
electronics hiss.
If it bothers you, swap headphones, turn the
volume down, or try a nicer cable, or better
audio encoder!
Sometimes, even using wireless connections
can reduce the hiss!
Or, you could think of it as you listening
to the sound of electrons moving, which I
think is pretty rad.
If you listen to music and podcasts and are
looking for a new Bluetooth speaker, try Monster’s
reimagined boombox, the Monster Blaster!
It’s available for monthly payments starting
at $25.
The Monster Blaster has the power to bring
music to life indoors and out.
Check it out at themonsterblaster.com/dnews.
Do you listen to music when you study?
Or work?
Does it help you stay focused?
Let us know in the comments and check out
this video for the science of listening to
music at work!
Oh, and subscribe because we love you, and
you love us.
Thanks for watching.